from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Nando's in the UK and India this
is food Wars
if you're ordering chicken for one
person it comes in three sizes at a UK
Nando's
as a quarter chicken
as a half chicken or
as a whole chicken
for one person here in Nando's India
comes in the form of a quarter chicken
which is one piece or a half chicken
which is two pieces you can also get a
whole chicken but it only comes in the
form of a sharing platter the largest of
which is a jumbo platter two whole
chickens and five large sides I'm
excited to eat this but all I need now
is friends so
hit me up
the largest item in the UK is the family
platter it comes with two whole chickens
as well as five large sides a family of
one
eat this what about some other things
from the Nando's menu well in the UK you
can get a grilled chicken burger in two
sizes as a single or as a double Nando's
India also sells chicken burgers and
offers customers the option to double
their chicken so you can get a single
chicken burger or double it to a double
chicken burger Nando's India serves
chicken wings but only in one size a
pack of four wings from a UK Nando's
come in four portion sizes as a three
piece there's a five piece there's a ten
piece and a 15 piece it's really weird
being the country with the biggest sizes
for a change Joe I miss you now the
classic side for any order of Nando's in
the UK is a side of Peri-Peri chips I'm
allowed to call them chips not fries
because Joe is not in this video in the
UK these come in two sizes regular and
large here in Nando's India they are
advertised not as chips but as fries
because that's what they are at Harry
you're weirdo I'm gonna weigh them you
get them in two sizes either regular or
large let me wear the regular
it's a hundred grams on the dot nice
next
418 grams no 408 grams 175 grams in the
large I don't know how to read
here is everything on the menu at a UK
now knows that you won't find in India
this is everything you'll find on the
menu at Nando's India that you will not
find in the UK we'll start with the
chicken now when you order chicken at
Nando's they'll ask you to pick a spice
level we have quite a few of these most
of which are shared with India except
for two firstly we have pimento spice I
think this is limited edition and it
sits somewhere between medium and hot on
the spice scale another exclusive spice
is Perry Tamer as the name suggests this
is quite a mild tame spice it's
somewhere between mild and basically
plain chicken I think it's a slightly
sweeter glaze than you might find on the
regular Peri-Peri spice here in India we
just get our chicken in the classic
scale of plain lemon and Herb mild
hot and extra hot I'm willing to bet
that our extra hot blows the UK extra
hot out of the water you see this tongue
this tongue can take spice oh my God is
this some kind of joke it's like
tickling me it's teasing me with spice
this is Child's Play I will say I love
how the UK Nando's has two extra flavors
I wish India Nando's experimented more
where in India dude there are so many
spices but what we lack in spices we
make up for in Mains number one creamy
cashew chicken with spicy rice
damn good okay now on to the next main
this is chicken cataplana cataplana is a
type of Portuguese clam shaped stove
cooking pot and they've also served it
with a yogurt dip so using a cataplan is
apparently healthier because you end up
using less fats to cook your meat and
your veggies next up we're having
chicken espetada or as I like to call it
chicken
I've been fired from the show 16 times
this season I imagine they take the
piece of chicken put them on skewers put
the marinade so Nando's is a Portuguese
inspired South African restaurant so
most of the recipes are things that were
developed by Portuguese explorers when
they were in South Africa we also have a
lot of Cuisine that's inspired by our
former Colonial overlords back in
Portugal in fact Goa which is a smallest
state here in India was where the
Portuguese first settled and so a lot of
the cuisine is derived and inspired by
Portuguese Cuisine we have a couple of
chicken Mains of our own starting with
boneless thighs these come in orders of
four and you can get them in any of the
standard Nando's spice levels and our
other chicken exclusive is this Wing
roulette so Wing roulette is an order of
10 wings and it's a variety of the
Nando's spices the idea is that you'll
get some of these share them with your
friends some of you might get hit with
an extra hot wing whereas others might
get off easy with a mile when I go to
Nando's I'm generally going for medium
or hot I'm not trying to be a hero I'm
going for extra hot I'm just not
actually going to taste the food it's
just going to kind of hurt I may also
add a little bit of the kind of garlic
and herb sauce which adds a little bit
of spice to it or also I've used ketchup
in the past which my friends have
lambasted me for so don't do that
good chicken though we also have some
meal deals these are more affordable
options and you will not find them in
the UK let's start off with the first
one which is pulled chicken sliders oh
my God this is like Gourmet dining I
think I would need to eat three of these
to feel considerably full Unfortunately
they only give you two next up is a
pulled chicken burger
oh my motherload of chicken that is a
lot of pulled chicken it needs a sauce
did I just eat a part that doesn't have
sauce next up we have chicken tegela
which is basically grilled chicken some
corn some roasted veggies and tomato and
this is served with some spicy rice
they've also given like a bunch of
veggies and I was really trying to get
our vitamins in but take a look at the
tegela itself it's got a bed of rice
underneath but on top there's some
pulled chicken a lot of grilled onions
and a lot of finely chopped capsicum
next up you have the option of a pulled
chicken wrap I mean it looks like a wrap
or you can also get a pulled chicken
pita
damn this looks like a donor Kebab I
guess the true test of whether Nando's
is putting a lot of effort into their
food is whether they're wraps and their
Pita tastes good
let's go
miles better than any other fast food
restaurant alongside those you can get a
tub of veggies so next up is chicken
skewers for a kebab eating Nation
good job Manus you get these along with
some pita bread and a couple of Salsas
you get a yogurt sauce and some salsa
next up we have Portuguese chicken and
gravy and if you can't tell from my face
I'm having a great time
oh boy
look at that it looks like there's dark
on top dude oh my God what is the tadka
you ask basically it's the best way to
finish up a curry here in India we take
oil heat it add some spices in there
temper them and then pour them over our
Curry and our final meal deal dish is
Saucy chicken strips in spicy rice I'm
not gonna lie this one looks like the
most boring option out of everything
here let's look at some of the burgers
and wraps from Nando's in the UK we have
a couple of exclusive options firstly we
have the sunset burger if a hat has it a
guess as to why this is called the
sunset Burger it might be because you
kind of get a sunset yellow orange red
effect going with the cheese the chicken
and the Chutney which looks very pretty
I haven't had this before I wouldn't
normally order it at Nando's but it's
actually very very good the bun is
slightly different to the regular burger
buns that we get it's a little bit more
kind of spongy and pillowy and that
Chutney stuff is delicious very sweet a
little bit Smoky then we also have the
Fino Peta I really love the packaging of
this it's great for delivery you just
tear straight through the middle not
like that
and then
pop that off
you have a nicely preserved upright
bitter now in a filo Pizza you get
chicken thighs you get some salad you
get Pyrenees you get halloumi and I
think there's also some caramelized
onions in there as well I'll be honest
I'm going to Nando's this is what I'm
getting it's kind of got all my favorite
Nando's things in one little package
they took it off the menu for the
pandemic they've recently brought it
back which I am thrilled about because I
missed it dearly
The Cheeky Nando's levels off the charts
right now we have a couple of exclusive
burgers and wrap flavors of our own
starting with the chicken Caesar salad
wrap
I kind of like that Packaging
let's see how this tastes
that is a messed up way to eat a wrap
eat it from the top not from the side
please nikhil
wow next up is the petty cheeseburger
which also comes as a wrap or in Pita
form look at the juice is dripping off
this thing man
that's what I'm talking about this
flavor has just achen India by storm in
the past few decades it's part of the
trifecta of ingredients that are red
velvet matcha and periperi the people
just love to put into every menu over
here Peri-Peri if you don't know is a
spice mix that was discovered by
Portuguese explorers when they were
settling slash pillaging South African
countries like South Africa and
Mozambique on the subject of foreigners
coming to a place and taking things from
it I would like to formally apologize to
India from the UK feel free to come and
take your stuff back from the British
museum whenever it's convenient I feel
like most Indians identify Peri-Peri as
the little packets of Peri-Peri you get
at McDonald's and you pour them into
your fries and shake them to get
Peri-Peri fries I feel like when they
come to Nando's they might find it not
spicy enough if you don't eat meat
Nando's is actually pretty good for
vegetarian and vegan options in the UK
first up we have the great imitator wrap
it doesn't look very appealing right now
however the great imitator is Nando's
version of fake chicken I think it's
made with pea protein and by all
accounts I've heard it's pretty good
then we have the beanie Burger
as the name would suggest it's a bean
Patty also comes with I believe an
egg-free Mayo some salad as well then we
have a spiced chickpea Burger it's kind
of similar to the beanie Burger however
once again as the name would suggests
the Patty is predominantly made of
chickpeas this one actually mirrors the
sunset Burger a little more because it's
got the same bun and also has some of
that red pepper Chutney and then finally
we have a portobello mushroom and
halloumi Pitta it's a pita bread with a
big portobello mushroom inside as well
as some salad some halloumi and more of
that red pepper Chutney pretty much
every fast food restaurant here in India
serves vegetarian food because a huge
percentage of the country is vegetarian
having said that Nando's actually had
quite a few non-vegetarian options which
is very cool to see in a restaurant like
this so let's go off the list of
vegetarian food now starting with creamy
cashew paneer and spicy rice so this is
the same thing as the creamy cashew
chicken except they've replaced it with
chunks of cottage cheese and it just
looks delicious let's see if Nando's has
done paneer right
it's really nice and it's not as chewy
it's soft soft paneer at a fast food
chain unheard of the next vegetarian
dish is called something exotic it's a
mystery even they don't know what it
could be and it is
what the heck I okay I did not expect to
see this it's watermelon and paneer
you know Nando's watermelon and paneer
you really are walking the line between
creativity and Abomination
no those are kind of weird together but
I think overall it was a fun dish and
they serve it along with a three bean
salad the three beans are
chickpea rajma and some other one let's
taste
even this is flavorful what's going on
okay now we're moving on to a vegetarian
version of the cataplana they have
tossed the same vegetables but this time
along with paneer and some chickpea I'm
gonna taste the chickpea
very nice this is easily the best food
I've had on food Wars
hands okay next up we have a vegetarian
version of the espetada as well
this
this is probably the best wedge skewer
I've seen in my life it's just too
beautiful I can't eat it I must frame
this in my home also they serve garlic
bread because this isn't enough
apparently the first one is a veg burger
they serve it with coleslaw
it's another milk frozen patty it's all
right this is probably the most
underwhelming thing on the menu so far
and finally they have a mushroom and
paneer Burger both of these options you
can get along with a wrap or pita
they have put a huge chunk of paneer in
there have you seen a paneer this big I
didn't even know they made this [ __ ]
Super Burger when there's good food in
the show I'm so happy and that's not all
there are more vegetarian options from
the meal deal section let's go from the
top first off we have wedge sliders
these ones have patties instead of
pulled chicken next up you can get a veg
together this one has paneer so same
thing it's a bed of rice some chopped
veggies on top but with paneer as the
protein it's served along with potato
wedges next up we have paneer skewers
that you can get along with either
spiced rice or with some pita bread very
similar to the skewers we had with
chicken and they seem to have the same
sauce as well they're served along with
either pita bread or spice rice you can
choose which option of side and you also
get a salsa as well as a yogurt dip I
always feel like it's hard to do skewers
with paneer because it's such a delicate
ingredient that if you fry too much it
gets too rubbery oh is that a piece of
pineapple then oh it's a lot of thought
put into these dishes Nando's is a class
apart it's just a class apart and
finally we have a very simple option at
the end it's a roasted veg and some
grilled paneer I'll probably skip this
one next up the UK exclusive starters
first up we've got some sweet potato
wedges and garlic Pyrenees
for some reason they've also mixed in a
bunch of regular chips as well I don't
know if that's normal because I'm
traditionally not going to order sweet
potato fries if you've watched free Wars
for a long time you will know my
thoughts on sweet potato namely that
they are bad
it's just like someone took a chip
and went how can we make this floppier
I know
the garlic Pyrenees however very tasty
would recommend getting a side of this
next time you're in Nando's also
exclusive to the UK are Peri Peri nuts
you can start your meal off with a
combination of I think cashews almonds
and maybe macadamia nuts all coated in
their signature Peri-Peri spice I'm
usually pretty good at this let's find
out
in the UK you can also get fried
halloumi sticks and a dip of your choice
however unfortunately the restaurant
forgot ours here's what they're supposed
to look like
neither of these are exclusive but in
both countries you can also start with
hummus and olives India has a variety of
options starting with the cheesy Fiesta
phrase seems pretty straightforward but
let's see if it is a fiesta oh my God
bro that presentation is off the charts
look at this
look at this every Marvel at the
presentation
okay I will say it's been in the cold
for a while so they may not taste as
good as when they're fresh
and I am right next up they have cheesy
Fiesta Chicken
boom it's pulled chicken grilled onions
same cheese and I imagine there's fries
underneath next up they have something
called the sweet potato and corn snack
whoa why is their food so beautiful
there's corn there's uh bits of red
paprika some chopped parsley but also
it's pieces of thinly sliced lemon
that's new
oh
are you supposed to eat that it's
interesting I don't know if I'd serve
lemon pieces in my salad next up we have
uh four piece wings but these ones are
spicy Tangy Wings they look quite
delicious
sprinkle some lemon on there
I'm disproportionately jealous of that
little lemon wedge with the wings why
don't we have that very little touch
lovely bit of freshness to your wing
forget about it I have to be honest
pretty blind not tasting any spice not
getting any Tang these are the most
underwhelming things on the menu so far
and now for something I did not expect
to see on the Nando's menu at all we
have a creamy cashew paneer and chicken
naan more like Nando's am I right guys
bro
why is all their food looking like art
that I can hang up on my wall okay so
this naan has the chicken so this is the
non-veg naan
let's go ahead and take a bite see how
it tastes
it was damn good the gravy on top is
very similar to a butter chicken it's
got a lot of sweetness and richness you
can tell there's cashew in it but
they've also sprinkled on a lot of green
chili some coriander and chopped onions
so there is a nice thicker spice and it
just drizzled a lot of Malai on top so
it's creamy this is what it would be
like if India had to have a pizza
banging also they serve it with
something called perines dip
are you sure this is for this
let's just avoid
it's just like a huge tub of mayonnaise
but it's perines apparently for those
looking for a healthier option Nando's
also offers salads there are two main
options in the UK firstly we have this
quinoa and Perry tomato salad this
actually looks pretty good I have to say
it looks like kind of sun-dried tomatoes
some lettuce some dressing some of these
little crunchy Crouton cracker things
and of course quinoa and our other salad
option is the delightfully named Rainbow
Bowl
now the very colorful rainbow bowl comes
with some hummus some coleslaw some
tennis and broccoli there's some grains
down in the corner and I think some
shredded carrot as well I love
tenderstem broccoli and we'll fight for
the death tennis and broccoli by default
the salads come plain but you can also
add chicken breast chicken thighs fake
chicken or beanie patties to any of them
here at Nando's India we have salad
options of our own starting with the
Mediterranean salad
is that something Mediterranean next up
we have an Algarve salad looks pretty
much the same minus the olives plus some
cashew nuts and a lot of sun-dried chili
or tomatoes then we have a quinoa salad
for those of you who are monsters and
can't eat rice like a normal person and
finally we have a Caesar salad and the
Caesar salad comes with a dressing now
all of those salads we ordered are
vegetarian but you can optionally get
some chicken strips if you need more
protein in there then we're on to the
sides in the UK you can get quite a few
exclusive sides to go along with your
Peri-Peri chips first up we have rainbow
slaw which is coleslaw filled with
Skittles no it's not it's just Coastal
they're kind of colorful we also have a
mixed leaf salad
a little box of leaves oh there's some
tomato and cucumber in there as well
this one is spiced grains with butternut
squash which actually sounds pretty good
some grains in there I think that's feta
cheese
some green beans and butternut squash
next up we have creamy mashed potato
it's mashed potato you can also get a
side of just some long stem broccoli
this one looks a little more sad than
the one that was on the salad but still
great
here's some garlic in there as well nice
touch and then finally we can get Macho
peas peas for Macho men just like me
I wasn't really sure where to put these
but there are a couple of extra things
which you can add onto pretty much any
order so I guess they kind of count as
sides first up you can just buy a couple
of pieces of grilled halloumi from
anandos in the UK for those of you who
don't know halloumi is a cheese which I
think is made with sometimes a mixture
of sheep and goat's milk predominantly
produced in Cyprus it's an interesting
cheese when you bite into it it doesn't
really give it's got a kind of like
rubbery texture I personally find it
very satisfying to eat as do a lot of
British people I think we're responsible
for something like 80 of the Cypress
halloumi consumption in the world which
is kind of wild but yeah it's pretty
good
it like squeaks on your teeth when you
eat it the other sorts of side options
include just one whole portobello
mushroom
this might have looked okay when it was
hot you can also just get a single plain
tortilla from Nando's
I guess the idea is that you could kind
of buy maybe the halloumi the mushroom
and a couple of other bits and sauces
and create your own wrap or own burrito
situation
personally
think it's worth doing that just buy a
pre-assembled one options for sides here
at an Indian Nando's you can get potato
wedgies I already showed veggies no no
they're not veggies the potato wedges
run in the middle potato veggies you can
also get some Char grilled veg in fact
they give you a lot you can also get a
three bean salad which looks really
colorful and has like a soupy liquid
that I want to try
lentil soup you say nay I want three
bean salad water
next up we have a Portuguese salad looks
pretty straightforward I have no idea
what makes this Portuguese is it the
olives probably and finally you can just
get a tub of feta cheese they've given
me six cubes of feta cheese
yeah
cool Nando's actually has quite a few
dessert options in the UK if you're in
store many of the shops will have an
option for bottomless frozen yogurt so
you can have that in the flavors of
vanilla strawberry chocolate or mango
install and also on delivery you can get
a few more options including a naughty
nata this is Nando's take on a
Portuguese egg custard tart AKA Pasto de
nada
probably butcher the pronunciation of
that if I take myself out to Nando's and
I'm feeling uh bougie I'll probably end
my meal with one of these because I love
these things we can also get a salted
caramel brownie I don't know that it's
very pretty it's got little gold
sprinkles on it
I'm describing More Foods as pretty just
in the theme of today but they are kind
of pretty
next we have a chocolate cake
which is a slice of what looks like a
pretty good gooey kind of indulgent
chocolate cake
pretty moist and then we also have this
gooey caramel cheesecake this is
actually really good I'm a cheesecake
fan but this is a great example of a
cheesecake I had it for the first time I
think when we filmed the UK versus US
Nando's go watch it now highly recommend
we don't shed any desserts with the UK
but we have our own desserts starting
with an ice cream and hot chocolate
where they don't deliver it so here's an
image of it I guess looks pretty good
looks nice then we have a series of
cakes starting with a chocolate cake
it's parcel in a burger case which is
kind of weird but dude look at this it's
a thick moist
fat cake I must taste for science
appropriately humid next up a red velvet
cake what did I say the trifecta of
ingredients I am surprised there's no
matcha milkshake at the end of this they
have to fit in red velvet in every
restaurant Peri-Peri red velvet and
matcha
and finally we have an out and out
cheesecake honestly all of these
desserts are okay I probably skipped the
dessert here last but by no means the
least let's talk about the drinks if you
go into a restaurant at bernardo's in
the UK you can get bottomless fizzy
drinks including coke diet coke Coke
Zero Sprite and Fanta now some people
will ask for a free glass of tap water
and then use that other fizzy drink
fountains to help themselves to free
fizzy drinks but I personally have
definitely never done that and would not
encourage that kind of flagrantly
illegal Behavior whatsoever
on delivery we do also have a few
exclusive drink options first options
are these bottle green cordials for
those of you who aren't familiar with
cordials it's like a flavor concentrate
so what you'll do is you'll put a few
splashes of this into a glass top it up
with water and then you have a drink
which you can actually consume I kind of
thought these would come pre-mixed so I
was a little bit surprised to see just
bottles of The Cordial itself but I
guess you can uh make sell some squash
at home this is Rooibos
right out
robust teas which are flavored with
things like lemon Peach and Berry and
finally we have gingerella by Karma
drinks this is just a ginger ale
we can also get bottomless soda refills
here in India but our bottled options
are fresh lime soda and two iced tea
options wait I don't know fresh them
server is a big thing abroad but over
here in India it is the number one drink
for middle class families when you go to
their family each person of the family
has a different order for fresh lime
soda Some Like It with just salt some
like it just sweet Some Like It with
sweet and salt and some monsters like it
with no salt or sugar this is from a
company called Brew House a tea brewing
company this is supposed to be a Mojito
lemon iced tea it's nice and next to
Peach Iced Tea
Nando's also offers these drinks called
designer drinks which seem to be
non-alcoholic soft drink cocktails it
seems like they just took seven up and
Blended them to form different flavors
with different colors but I'm curious to
see if they actually taste good color
color which color do you choose let's
try the Virgin mojito ah tastes like a
Mojito without the alcohol
you can see they've gone the extra mile
they're put in fresh lemon a lot of mint
in there
next one is Citra which I assume is a
Mandarin slash orange flavor dream
very delicious super refreshing I
thought this could be something we could
make fun of Nando's for but they've
actually made some delicious refreshing
drinks if dip do the cats cut the flu
the dogs got the chickenpox and so have
you Portuguese lemonade let's go what
makes it Portuguese I don't know maybe
it's olive oil let's see this is really
um so it's not all sweet it has like
some sort of powder at the bottom is it
Peri-Peri powder I don't know but it
tastes like Chaat powder that they put
in a lot of lemon sodas here in India
and it's really yum Peach and
elderflower they've actually put a slice
peach in there these are certified
designer drinks
half a chicken Peri-Peri chips and
garlic bread at the UK Nando's will cost
you 13 pounds and 10 pence that same
meal in India will cost you rupees 869
which at the time of filming this video
is equal to 9.85 pounds that's almost 25
percent cheaper of a meal than the one
in the UK okay now while you Brits might
feel hard done by because of these price
differences I must say that this is
actually super expensive for a single
meal for a single person here in India
in fact most people in this country
would find that almost aspirational you
can get meals here for close to 100
rupees that's less than a pound I would
say that I can't even consider this fast
food it is the most expensive restaurant
we've tried here on food Wars but the
food was Top Class throughout so I guess
it makes sense now Nando's does have
some slightly more affordable options in
the form of meal deals where you can get
a single meal for around 400 rupees
which is equal to 4.5 pounds this
doesn't seem like a significant upgrade
and it isn't in fact the state that
we're filming this video is Karnataka
here in India and the daily wage is
around 500 rupees so you would have to
literally work an entire day to afford a
single meal here in Nando's in fact my
first salary as an intern was 10 000
rupees per month which is 125 pounds per
month and so if I ordered a cheeky
Nando's it would literally be nearly one
tenth of my entire monthly salary I'm
not sure I'd consider Nando is an
affordable option in the UK and I'm not
even really sure I'd consider it fast
food is it somewhere in that kind of
fast casual bracket combining elements
of fast food restaurants with elements
of the more traditional dining
experience some Brits don't really like
Nando's and might claim that it's kind
of overrated I personally love Nando's
it's fast it's consistent and I have a
kind of cultural attachment to it as I
was kind of a teenager when it really
blew up in popularity here in the UK I
might be able to get more value for
money at somewhere like a KFC but to me
it wouldn't hit the same
unfortunately Nando's in the UK doesn't
disclose a full ingredients list Nando's
in India also doesn't disclose a full
ingredient list so what do we know about
the food well the FAQ pages on our
respective websites do share some clues
for example in the UK Nando says it uses
red tractor assured chicken from British
Farms to be red track to certified
chickens must be raised with certain
benefits such as no cages and natural
light the Indian FAQ page says that all
of Nando's Chicken in India is sourced
from India and it's all cage-free they
also say that all the chickens are a
grade now I don't know what this means
because it's hard to keep up with
up-to-date poultry practices here in
India but one report from 2012 said that
a top grade chicken must be free of
deformities that detract from its
appearance or that affect the normal
distribution of Flesh slight deformities
such as slightly curved or dented breast
bones and slightly curved backs may be
present now this sounds kind of vague
but I do hope that Nando's is following
this practice and only sourcing some a
grade chickens because that's what it
tasted like some a great
one other thing we can glean from the
FAQ page is that the great imitator wrap
might not be as plant-based as Nando's
seems to think it is this is because
both the tortilla wrap and also the
glaze used on the chicken contains
shellac Sherlock is a substance used in
food as a glazing agent but it's found
in various other things such as nail
polish fireworks and sealants The Twist
is that it's technically an animal
product it's a resin secreted by lack
beetles female lack beetles will secrete
it onto trees in the forests of India
and Thailand where it's then harvested
processed and sold for use the bugs
countless animals for the purpose of
veganism I'm a meat eater so I can't
really talk but in my opinion I don't
think a bug should count I think that's
fine hey everyone it's Harry Kirsch from
the food Wars team I finally got to meet
my co-host Joe Avella for a cool new
project we're working on called Food
Tours here's a trailer for it now
foreign
can I shock you Joe
I quite like this
oh yeah
yo what's up with that egg over there
what is that that's the gherkin oh what
is it really it's literally the guy
again
people of the internet you cannot expect
me to pick this up with my hands
oh man you know what Hattie up till now
I didn't get the whole cheeky Nando's
meme but now I kind of get it I feel
like they're having a lot of fun with
all the food that they're serving and I
had so much fun eating all of the food I
feel like India should have its own
version of The Cheeky Nando's we're
gonna call it the chalu nandos because
chalu means kind of cheeky in Hindi